SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO ON RESOURCES,
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
ENERGY WILL COME TO ORDER. I ASK
ALL MEMBERS TO BE PRESENT ROOM
2200 SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR HEARING.
FOR TODAY'S HEARING, ALL ITEMS
ARE VOTE ONLY. AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT ON THESE
ISSUES AND THEN MOVE TO THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR FOR THE ISSUES WE
ARE VOTING ON TODAY HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED IN SEVERAL
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS. WE'VE
HEARD AND APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. THE ACTIONS WE WILL BE
TAKING TODAY REPRESENT THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET PLAN. THIS
IS A VERY DIFFICULT BUDGET YEAR,
MEANING THAT WE HAVE SOME VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS, AS I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE ASSEMBLY
IN A COLLABORATIVE AND
THOUGHTFUL MANNER AS WE MOVE
TOWARDS A FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS. I'D LIKE
TO START BY ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BECKER. HERE. BECKER. HERE.
BLAKE. SPEER DOLLY. DOLLY. HERE
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM. AND I'D
LIKE TO. POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE, I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR DOLLY FOR HIS SERVICE ON
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE. I WAS JUST
INFORMED. I GUESS I SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN. I HAVEN'T REALLY QUITE
HIT IN. THIS IS OUR LAST
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE YEAR. AND SO
, YOU'VE SERVED ON THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR MANY YEARS.
I'VE ENJOYED SERVING WITH YOU ON
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I KNOW
THERE ARE CERTAIN MATTERS I CAN
JUST TURN OVER TO YOU BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING TO YOU'RE GOING TO
GO FULL SPEED AHEAD ON THEM.
AND, AND WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
ALIGNED ON MORE THINGS THAN,
THAN NOT. SO, I KNOW THESE
ISSUES ARE ARE ALMOST EVERYTHING
WE DISCUSS HERE IS, IS, MISSION
CRITICAL TO YOUR DISTRICT, YOUR
VAST DISTRICT. SO WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SERVICE ON THIS COMMITTEE.
SURE. WELL, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
AND I JUST WANT TO, FIRST OF
ALL, THANK MY TEAM, FOR ALL THE
YEARS OF BEING HERE, HEATHER AND
EMILY, FOR THE HELP. AND ALSO
CARRIE, WHO STEPPED IN ON SOME
OF THE ENERGY STUFF THAT'S BEEN
VERY. AND YOUR STAFF AS WELL.
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF, BEEN
VERY FORTUNATE TO SIT ON THE
COMMITTEE. LOVE IT. IT'S ONE OF
MY FAVORITE COMMITTEES. AND, YOU
KNOW, AT THE END OF THE DAY AND
TO ALL THE LAO AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ALL THE FOLKS
THAT SPEND THE TIME BEHIND THE
SCENES DRILLING DOWN AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE ASK FOR AND NEED
TO MAKE GOOD, SOLID DECISIONS.
AND I JUST SAY, YOU KNOW, AS A
FARMER, I ALWAYS, HAVE THIS
PHILOSOPHY. THE LAND NEVER LIES.
YOU KNOW, WE TELL LOTS OF
STORIES IN HERE, AND WE HAVE
LOTS OF. BUT THERE'S SOME TRUTH
SOMEWHERE OUT THERE, THERE'S A
LOT OF SPIN IN THIS, IN THIS
BUILDING. BUT I ALWAYS SAY THE
TRUTH IS, SOMEWHERE. AND I SAY,
AS A FARMER, THE LAND NEVER
LIES. IF YOU MAKE A MISTAKE. FOR
EXAMPLE, FIRE IS SOMETHING
WE'VE. YOU KNOW, HAD POLICIES ON
AND IT TELLS A STORY. IF YOU GO
OUT AND LOOK AT IT, WELL,
THERE'S A STORY BEHIND ALL THE
POLICIES WE MAKE HERE WITH ALL
THE STAFF DOING THE HARD WORK.
AND SO I WANT TO JUST THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE LAO, ALL
THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE THAT DON'T
GET RECOGNIZED. IT'S BEEN A VERY
GREAT PRIVILEGE TO SIT ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND WORK WITH A GREAT
SENATOR. SO THANK YOU FOR, THIS
IS MY LAST MEETING, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEE HOW THE BUDGET
COMES OUT. AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT
I'M GOING TO DO IN THE FUTURE.
I'VE BEEN ELECTED 29 YEARS
STRAIGHT, AND IT'LL BE THE
FIRST, YEAR THAT I DON'T HAVE TO
GO TO A MEETING SOMEWHERE. AND
SO, MY FAMILY'S A LITTLE NERVOUS
. THEY'RE NOT SURE WHAT TO WHAT
I'M GOING TO DO. BUT ANYWAY, I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR ALL
THE GOOD HARD WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE HERE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. WELL, PUBLIC COMMENT IS
ALWAYS AVAILABLE, SO, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE YOU CAN REACH OUT TO US
PRIVATELY OR YOU CAN COME JOIN
US IN PUBLIC COMMENT. AND, AND
SO WITH THAT, WE WILL TURN TO
PUBLIC COMMENT AND, THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO. FIRST, WE
WILL INSTITUTE A TIME LIMIT, ASK
FOLKS TO, SPEAK FOR, FOR NO MORE
THAN, THAN TWO MINUTES AND,
BEGIN BY STATING YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. AND DO WE HAVE
ANYONE HERE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT?
PLEASE LINE UP AND START. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, I'M NOT SHY, GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND SENATORS.
HAPPY LAST HEARING, I'LL BE
REALLY SHORT. ISABELLA GONZALEZ,
POTTER WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. WE ARE DISAPPOINTED
THAT THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
REJECTED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO SHIFT THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD FUNDING TO
GRF. VERY DISAPPOINTED WITH THAT
CHANGE. THIS FUNDING REALLY IS
CRITICAL TO ADVANCE CONSERVATION
AND BIODIVERSITY PRIORITIES AS
WE GRAPPLE WITH THE INCREASING
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. THANK
YOU, GOOD MORNING, KYLE JONES,
POLICY AND LEGAL DIRECTOR WITH
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR APPROVING FUNDING TO SUPPORT
TWO OF OUR SPONSOR BILLS LAST
YEAR, SB THREE, TO PREVENT
ILLEGAL SHUT OFFS, AND AB 664 TO
HELP RENTERS ACCESS SAFE
DRINKING WATER. ALSO THANKFUL
FOR SUPPORT FOR SB 659 BY ASHBY
TO SUPPORT DRINKING WATER
QUALITY DURING RECHARGE
PROJECTS. AND THEN FINALLY, JUST
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
PRESERVING SOME FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WATER AND
WASTEWATER. WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO AND SO THIS FUNDING IS
HELPFUL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS AS PART
OF THE CLIMATE BOND DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS SAM GREENLEE. I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF ALCHEMIST COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND ON BEHALF OF THE
MORE THAN 250 ORGANIZATIONS WHO
MAKE UP THE SAVE MARKET MATCH
COALITION, I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY SINCERE GRATITUDE TO THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEES FOR PRESERVING 33.2
MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NUTRITION INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
ALSO KNOWN AS CNP, WHICH FUNDS
MARKET MATCH MARKET MATCH
PROVIDES A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
MATCH ON CAL FRESH SPIN FARM
DIRECT SITES ACROSS THE STATE.
WE RECOGNIZE THE INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGES AND BALANCING THE
STATE BUDGET AND THE MANY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT WERE
MADE. AND WE WANT TO COMMEND YOU
AND FELLOW STATE LEADERS FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT CNP IS NOT ONLY
A LIFELINE FOR FOOD INSECURE
FAMILIES, BUT ALSO SUPPORTS
SMALL AND MID-SIZED FARMERS AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES, AND REDUCES
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY
REDUCING TRAVEL DISTANCE FROM
FARM TO TABLE. WE HOPE THE FINAL
STATE BUDGET ACT, SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR, WILL FULLY FUND 35
MILLION FOR CNP, WHICH WAS
PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED IN THE 2023
2024 BUDGET. AND WITH STATE
SENATE FUNDING. CALIFORNIA WILL
BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
MATCHING GRANT FUNDING FROM THE
USDA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR ONGOING
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU. MICHAEL.
JARED, ON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA AND THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS,
FIRST, I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY ALCHEMIST ON
THE CNET PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR
THAT FUN SHIFT. IN ADDITION, I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, FOR THE PRESERVING
THE CALIFORNIA UNDERSERVED SMALL
PRODUCER PROGRAM AND THE FOOD
HUBS PROGRAM. THESE ARE VITALLY
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS TO HELP SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS DEAL WITH THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE, AND
ALSO MAKE MORE RESILIENT FOOD
SYSTEMS. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS BUDGET. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, RYAN SOUZA, ON BEHALF
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE,
IN AN EFFORT TO KEEP THIS SHORT,
I JUST WANT TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
TO THE COLLEAGUES BEFORE ME ON
THE INCLUSION OF THE CNET
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. I'M SHORT.
HI, MR. CHAIR MEMBERS, KENDRA
HARRIS WITH THE CLIMATE CENTER
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR PRESERVING SOME IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS IN CLIMATE PROGRAMS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S A TOUGH YEAR,
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE PROGRAM.
EQUITABLE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION AND OTHER EQUITY
, INVESTMENTS. WE WANT TO ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO GET A CLIMATE
BOND, AND AS WELL AS ELIMINATE
ALL OIL AND GAS SUBSIDIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, THOSE MONEY
CAN GO BACK INTO THE GENERAL
FUND AND SUPPORT CLIMATE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI, I'M SUSIE SUTPHIN,
REPRESENTING THE CENTER FOR LAND
BASED LEARNING, AND I TOO, AM
HERE TO GIVE THANKS FOR
RESTORING THE FUNDING FOR CNP
AND HELPING TO SAVE MARKET
MATCH. I STEPPED AWAY FROM OUR
MOBILE FARMERS MARKET JUST
TODAY, SO I COULD COME AND SHOW
MY APPRECIATION, WE ARE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE COIN. NOT ONLY ARE
WE GOING DIRECTLY INTO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT MOST,
IT'S MOBILE. SO FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE MAYBE EVEN MOBILITY
ISSUES, WE'RE GOING TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE UNDERSERVED
AS WELL AS PROVIDING NEW MARKETS
FOR BEGINNING AND NEW SMALL
FARMERS. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. BILL
MAGAVERN WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR. THIS BUDGET
UNFORTUNATELY, IS CLEARLY A
SETBACK FOR AIR AND CLIMATE
PROTECTION. BUT I DO WANT TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR AND
PARTICULARLY THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR INCLUDING IN YOUR PROPOSAL,
PROVISIONS THAT WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE UP AND RUNNING
SUCCESSFULLY IN THE AIR,
DISTRICTS ARE ABLE TO KEEP GOING
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME RETAINING
FUNDING TO GET THE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM OFF THE GROUND. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE CARB BCP'S AND THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION IN. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, TOM
KNOX OF CLEAN AIR NOW WANT TO,
TO ECHO BILL MCGOVERN'S COMMENTS
ON CLEAN CARS FOR ALL? THANK YOU
FOR THE PROPOSAL TO REALLOCATE
THAT FUNDING. IT'S A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE WAY TO KEEP THE
EXISTING FIVE AIR DISTRICT
PROGRAMS FOR CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
GOING, WHILE ALLOWING CARB TO
OTHER PROGRAMS TO LAUNCH THIS.
THIS PRESERVES THE ONE PROVEN
SOLUTION FOR ZEV EQUITY OUT
THERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, DOCTOR JEFF BOEHM WITH
THE MARINE MAMMAL CENTER
REPRESENTING THE 12 NETWORK
MEMBERS THAT DO THIS WORK UP AND
DOWN THE CALIFORNIA COAST FROM
SAN DIEGO COUNTY UP TO THE
OREGON BORDER. WE APPRECIATE THE
RESTORATION OF THE FUNDING FOR
THIS NETWORK. THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS WORK, THE STRESSES ON THE
OCEAN HAVE NEVER BEEN GREATER.
AND WE'RE THAT VANGUARD THAT IS
OUT THERE ON THE FRONT LINES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU. HI. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS VIRGIL LOONEY AND I WORK
AT CCDC, AND WE'RE LEADING UP
THE EFFORT TO STAND UP THE
STATEWIDE FINANCING ASSISTANCE
AND CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM.
AND SO I'M HERE TO ASK TO NOT
REDUCE OUR FUNDING IN HALF, THIS
CUT IS GOING TO DELAY THINGS
FURTHER. AND AS WE STAND RIGHT
NOW, WE'RE ALREADY UNDER
CONTRACT WITH CARB. WE'RE
ALREADY UNDER CONTRACT WITH KEY
PARTNERS AND WITH OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE RELYING ON THESE FUNDS.
AND SO TO CUT IT IN HALF IS
GOING TO HAVE A DRAMATIC IMPACT
ON OUR ABILITY TO NOT ONLY REACH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
UNDERSERVED AND UNDER-RESOURCED
FOR YEARS, BUT THEN ALSO OUR
ABILITY TO COMPENSATE OUR CBO
PARTNERS FAIRLY ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE ALREADY
DEEP INTO OUR PROGRAM DESIGN AND
WELL ON OUR WAY TO LAUNCH THIS
PROGRAM THIS SUMMER. SO IF WE IF
WE IF WE IF WE HAVE TO, IF WE
HAVE TO MANAGE THIS REDUCTION IN
FUNDING, IT'S GOING TO CAUSE
MORE DELAY AND NEGATIVE IMPACTS
FOR THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SERVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI. NANCY WALSH YORK
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT, KRCD. I'M HERE TODAY
TO STRONGLY OPPOSE AND REALLY
IMPLORE YOU TO NOT CUT THE $7
MILLION IN FUNDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION'S
CLIMATE SMART LAND MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM. CRCD, ALONG WITH THE
SHERWOOD BAND OF POMO INDIANS,
THE SANTA CRUZ RCD AND THE
MENDOCINO RCD WERE ALL AWARDED
GRANTS UNDER THIS PROGRAM. IN
APRIL. PRIOR TO THE CUTS, KRCD
ACTUALLY HAS A SIGNED CONTRACT,
WE THE KRCD IS GOING TO USE THIS
MONEY PARTNERING WITH CDFA TO
PULL IN FEDERAL FUNDING THROUGH
THE RCPP PROGRAM, $25 MILLION OF
FEDERAL FUNDING TO GET
CONSERVATION ON THE GROUND IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT PRETTY MUCH
FALLS APART IF WE LOSE THIS
FUNDING BECAUSE WE WERE BASING
CAPACITY BUILT UNDER THAT
FUNDING FOR THAT REQUEST AND THE
COMBINED IMPACTS OF ALL THE,
FOUR GRANTS UNDER THAT PROGRAM,
WOULD BE WOULD BE REALLY BAD.
THEY WILL BE CREATING JOBS,
BOOSTING LOCAL ECONOMIES AND
HELPING THE STATE ACHIEVE 30 BY
30 CLIMATE GOALS. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THEY'LL BE SAVING
THE COUNTY, THE STATE MONEY BY
PREVENTING WILDFIRES THAT AFFECT
HEALTH AND SAFETY. SO I REALLY
WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT THAT
CAREFULLY. AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. TASHA NEWMAN,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF LAND TRUSTS,
PENINSULA OPEN SPACE TRUST, THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
AUTHORITY, BOLSA CHICA LAND
TRUST, AND BIG SUR LAND TRUST.
WE'RE HERE TODAY, VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSED
REJECTION TO BACKFILL THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD'S
FUNDING WITH GRF. I KNOW THERE
WAS, ONE PROGRAM THAT IS, SLATED
TO GET FUNDING. HOWEVER, $112
MILLION LOOKS LIKE IT WON'T BE
FUNDED IF THE GRF BACKFILL
DOESN'T HAPPEN. SO WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
THERE ARE SHOVEL READY PROJECTS,
READY TO GO, READY TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HELP THE
STATE ACHIEVE ITS 30 BY 30
GOALS. WE ARE ALSO THANKFUL THAT
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND IS
PROTECTED GOING FORWARD.
HOWEVER, WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE $45 MILLION CUT TO THAT
FUND. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY, AND I WOULD LIKE TO URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO PASS A
CLIMATE BOND THIS YEAR. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. HI THERE MEGAN
MEKELBURG ON BEHALF OF TWO
DIFFERENT CLIENTS TODAY. SO
FIRST I'LL START WITH CALSTART.
WE'RE REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CUTS TO CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTIES OF
INCENTIVES, SO NO NEW MONEY FOR
THAT ONE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE REALLY
JUST CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT SIGNAL
THIS SENDS TO THE MARKET AS WE
ARE ABOUT TO HIT THE FIRST, YOU
KNOW, GOALS IN ACF IN 2025,
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO EXPLORE OTHER MEANS OF
FUNDING, INCLUDING THROUGH A
CLIMATE BOND. SEPARATELY, ON
BEHALF OF THE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION COALITION, THÀNH
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
RESTORATION OF FUNDS IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE EQUITABLE,
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION PROGRAM
AND APPRECIATE CHAIR BECKER'S
LEADERSHIP ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. Ó DIFRANCO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION, OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
CAL TC, CALTECH SUPPORTS THE
AGREEMENT, WHICH FOUND MORE
MONEY TO FUND THE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAM, FOR THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS. THESE PROGRAMS WOULD
HAVE RUN OUT OF MONEY, THIS
YEAR, LEAVING HUNDREDS OF LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN OUR
TRANSFORMATIVE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE FUTURE. BUT FOR THE SAME
REASON YOU FOUND FUNDS FOR THE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL. WE ARE
ASKING YOU TO RESTORE $40
MILLION TO CONTINUE THE
TRANSITION TO MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY ZEVS THE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AT CARB
SUPPORTS THE PURCHASE OF THESE
VEHICLES AND IF NOT FUNDED IN
THIS FISCAL YEAR AS CURRENTLY
PROPOSED, IT IS AT RISK OF
RUNNING OUT OF FUNDS, RESULTING
IN A CHILLING EFFECT ON THE
MARKET AND VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT.
GIVEN THE DISPROPORTIONATE AND
NEGATIVE IMPACT THESE VEHICLES
HAVE IN TERMS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND GIVEN REGULATORY TIMING, IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN MDS
EVS. THIS YEAR. FINALLY, WE URGE
YOU TO RESTORE, 50 MILLION FOR
ZEV INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS
IN, THIS THIS IS THE MINIMUM WE
NEED. THIS NEXT FISCAL YEAR TO
CONTINUE OUR PROGRESS ON ZEV
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR LIGHT, MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY CHARGING. WE NEED
THIS THE MOST. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. I'M CATHERINE
FREEMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, AND WE REPRESENT ALL
58 COUNTIES, JUST TWO THINGS.
ONE IS TO SUPPORT AND THANK YOU
FOR THE INCLUSION AND
RESTORATION OF AN EXTREME HEAT
PACKAGE. WE NEED THAT VERY MUCH.
AND THEN SECOND, THE RESTORATION
OF THE CRITICAL DAM SAFETY
INFRASTRUCTURE. OUR COUNTIES
RELY ON THIS FOR THE SAFETY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, KIM STONE OF
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION, IN APPRECIATION FOR
THE LEGISLATURE ACTION TO,
DECLINE TO IMPOSE A FEE ON SOLAR
SELF-CONSUMPTION TO FUND THE
ENERGY RESOURCES PROGRAM
ACCOUNT, THE ARPA ACCOUNT. VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. WE'VE HAD A
ROUGH YEAR, AND YOU'RE NOT
MAKING IT ANY WORSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. NICHOLAS MAZZOTTI, ON
BEHALF OF EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARKS DISTRICT, MIDPENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT,
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE,
SEMPERVIRENS FUND AND THE LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY,
THANKING THE LEGISLATURE,
PARTICULARLY THE SENATE, FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN RESTORING
FUNDING FOR WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND THE STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY. WE BOAST OF
THESE. BOTH OF THESE AGENCIES DO
CRITICAL WORK THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND MAKE A LOT OF
INVESTMENTS IN OUR CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. SO THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THOSE RESTORATION
OR FUN SHIFTS TO GRF. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION, I'M EXPRESSING
CONCERN AROUND THE CUTS TO THE
COASTAL RESILIENCE FUNDING IN
STATE PARKS. THERE WAS ABOUT $11
MILLION INVESTED FOR THIS
PURPOSE IN THE NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS PACKAGE, AND THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL CUTS $6.7
MILLION OF THIS CRITICAL
FUNDING. STATE PARKS, THEY OWN,
YOU KNOW, A QUARTER OF THE
STATE'S COASTLINE. SO, YOU KNOW,
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE REALLY
CRITICAL. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CRYSTAL
STRAIT, ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
CLEAN POWER CALIFORNIA, REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEE'S WORK
, ESPECIALLY THE CHAIR, IN
MAKING SURE THAT OFFSHORE WIND,
PARTICULARLY, THROUGH OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE PORTS THAT
THAT MONEY WAS RESTORED, WE
APPRECIATE AND UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME OF THE MONEY IS STILL BEING
MOVED TO HANDLE, COASTAL
COMMISSION AND OTHER STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE NEEDED.
BUT WE CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THIS
SHOWS, AGAIN, THE COMMITMENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS CLEARLY
SHOWN FOR OFFSHORE WIND AND ITS
PRODUCTION. SO THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU, DAN
SCHORR, ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH, ECHOING THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE, OBVIOUSLY WE
WOULD, APPRECIATE FULL
RESTORATION OF THAT FUNDING, BUT
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
RECOGNITION THAT WITHOUT PORTS,
OFFSHORE WIND DOES NOT HAPPEN
WITHOUT UPGRADED PORTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. CHRIS
MICHELI ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY HERE,
URGING YOU TO KEEP GRF FUNDING
FOR TRANSPORTATION. THÀNH. THANK
YOU, SIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY, WELL THANK YOU. OH, WE
HAVE THE LAST PUBLIC COMMENT. I
WAS WONDERING WHEN YOU CAME IN
LIKE, OKAY, JORDAN CURLEY, ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN CLEAN POWER
HERE TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE RESTORATION OF THE FUNDS
TOWARDS OFFSHORE WIND. WE
APPRECIATE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. AND JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY EXCELLENT, WELL, GOOD.
WELL, WITH THAT, WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO VOTING AND WE'LL MOVE
NOW TO THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
SO I'M GOING TO FIRST ASK FOR A
MOTION, SO WE HAVE A THREE PARTS
TO THIS. IT LOOKS LIKE. SO WE
WERE GOING TO START WITH PART A.
AND I'D LOVE A MOTION ON ISSUES
FIVE THROUGH SEVEN, NINE THROUGH
17, 19, 21 TO 31, 33 TO 35, 39
TO 44, 49, 54 TO 57, 62, 72, 74
AND 75. YOU IN CALIFORNIA WON'T
APPRECIATE THIS, BUT GROWING UP
IN THE EAST COAST, WE USED TO
HAVE SCHOOL CLOSURES. WE'D HAVE
TO LISTEN TO THE RADIO TO SEE IF
YOUR SCHOOL WAS SHUT DOWN FOR
SNOW AND THEY WOULD READ OFF ALL
THE NUMBERS OF THE SCHOOLS, YOU
KNOW, BE LISTENING TO IF YOUR
NUMBER WAS CALLED. SO I FEEL
LIKE THAT WAS THAT WAS THE
FEELING I JUST GOT READING OFF
ALL THOSE NUMBERS. BUT, ANYWAY,
WE'D LOVE A MOTION ON THOSE, SO
MOVED BY SENATOR DONNELLY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BECKER I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR, I BLAKE
SPEAR, I DOLLY DOLLY I THOSE
ITEMS ARE APPROVED ON A 3 TO 0
VOTE, NOW, WE WOULD LIKE,
CONTINUING PART A, LIKE A MOTION
ON ISSUES THREE, FOUR, 18, 20,
32. YEAH. 20. YEAH. 32, 60, 67
AND 68. DO I HAVE A MOTION?
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BECKER I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR, I BLAKE
SPEAR I DOLLY DOLLY NÓ ON A 2 TO
1 VOTE. THOSE, ISSUES ARE
APPROVED, NOW, I WOULD LOVE A
MOTION ON ISSUES 128, 36, 37,
38, 45 TO 48, 50 TO 53, 58, 59,
61, 63 TO 66, 69 TO 71, AND 70,
83. MAY I HAVE A Ã MOTION? I'LL
MOVE. SENATOR BLAKE MOVES.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BECKER I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR. BLAKE
SPEAR. I DOLLY. DOLLY. NOT
VOTING 220 IS THE VOTE. AND
THOSE ISSUES ARE APPROVED. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR PART B, AND I
WOULD LIKE A MOTION FOR THOSE
FOR ISSUES 146 THROUGH NINE, 18,
24 TO 31, 34 TO 36, 38 TO 39, 41
AND 42. DO I HAVE A MOTION?
SENATOR DOLLY MOVES, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BECKER I, BECKER I
BLAKE SPEAR, I BLAKE SPEAR I
DOLLY. DOLLY I THE VOTE IS 3 TO
0 AND THOSE ARE ISSUES ARE
APPROVED. NOW I WILL HAVE A
MOTION ON ISSUES TWO, THREE,
FIVE, 11, 13 TO 17, 20 TO 22,
32, 37 AND 40. I HAVE A MOTION
SEN. BLAKE. SPEAR MOVES. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BECKER. I BECKER
I BLAKE SPEAR, I BLAKE SPEAR I
DOLLY. DOLLY NÓ. THE VOTE IS 2
TO 0. THOSE ISSUES ARE APPROVED.
AND FINALLY, ISSUES 1012, 19, 23
AND 33. LOVE OF MOTION. I'LL
MOVE. SEN. BLAKE. SPEAR MOVES.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BECKER. I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR. BLAKE
SPEAR I DOLLY. DOLLY. NOT VOTING
ISSUES. THE VOTE IS 2 TO 0. AND,
THOSE ARE APPROVED. MAKE SURE I
GOT FOR THE PREVIOUS ISSUE. IT
WAS 2 TO 1. THIS IS 2 TO 0.
THOSE ARE APPROVED, NOW FINALLY,
VOTE ONLY PART C WOULD LOVE A
EMOTIONAL ISSUES. ONE AND TWO.
I'LL MOVE. SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR
MOVES. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BECKER I BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR, I
BLAKE SPEAR I DOLLY DOLLY. NOT
VOTING. THE VOTE IS 2 TO 0. AND
THOSE ISSUES ARE, APPROVED, SO
WITH THAT I APPRECIATE, I JUST
WANT TO, I GUESS, TAKE A MOMENT
AND THANK MY TEAM HERE, OUR
CONSULTANTS WHO HAVE WORKED SO
HARD FOR THIS ENTIRE YEAR. YOU
KNOW, IN, IN GOOD BUDGET YEARS,
IT'S A SCRAMBLE BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO SEE WHAT WHAT, YOU
KNOW, WHAT CAN GET FIT IN. AND
TOUGH BUDGET YEARS WERE WERE,
OBVIOUSLY LOOKING AT, AT CUTS
AND TRYING TO MANAGE AGE, TO
MOVE, ALL OF OUR EFFORTS IN
CLEAN ENERGY AND REGENERATIVE
AGRICULTURE, IN FARMING AND
WATER AND SAFETY AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER, ALL THESE, YOU
KNOW, MOVE EVERYTHING FORWARD AS
BEST WE CAN, WHILE MAINTAINING
THE BEST BANG FOR THE BUCK. AND,
AND, YOU KNOW, AND MAKING SURE
THE CUTS HAVE THE LEAST, LEAST
HARM POSSIBLE AND SLOW OUR
MOMENTUM THE LEAST, AND THAT WE
KEEP IMPORTANT PROGRAMS MOVING
FORWARD. SO JUST APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF CONSULTANTS AND THE
TEAM. I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
MY, PERSONAL STAFF AND
PARTICULARLY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE LAO WHO HAS, BEEN HERE
AND HAVE ANSWERED ALL OF OUR
QUESTIONS, OF OUR MANY QUESTIONS
THROUGHOUT, THROUGHOUT THIS,
THIS, THIS DIFFICULT YEAR. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND, I THANKS
EVERYONE WHO'S PARTICIPATED.
THERE IS STILL THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PUT COMMENTS ON OUR WEBSITE,
THANKS, EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING OF THE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE. TWO, AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED TO.